- This video was brought
to you by BetterHelp.
(mid-tempo music)
What's up everybody?
Helen here with some thoughts
about "Stranger Things".
The content overlords at
Netflix finally dropped
the end of season four, and
according to popular opinion,
the Duffer brothers stuck the landing.
But while the show has
been praised for maturing
with season four, it hasn't
completely shaken criticism
that it relies too heavily on nostalgia.
Some see it as little more
than a gumbo of references
aimed at grown up '80s kids.
But in recent seasons it's
introduced plot points
that confront the darker
side of the 1980s,
and nostalgia in general,
choosing to actually examine the past
instead of just serving up more
of the warm and fuzzy
nostalgia we've come to expect.
And yet, these two approaches,
the comforting and the critical,
are also diametrically opposed,
which makes us wonder
can "Stranger Things"
subvert the very nostalgia it also evokes?
Let's take a look in
this Wisecrack Edition
can "Stranger Things" nostalgia grow up?
And spoilers ahead.
But before we dive in,
we wanna thank this video
sponsor, BetterHelp.
If you've been feeling
anxious, overwhelmed,
or depressed lately, BetterHelp can be
an excellent resource
to help you feel better.
I personally can't remember a time
when I didn't feel anxious or overwhelmed,
and the constant barrage of bad news
that seems to come every
minute of every hour
of every day now isn't making it easier.
But thankfully there
are resources out there.
BetterHelp's network of
more than 20,000 therapists
are ready to listen and support you.
After completing a short questionnaire,
you'll be matched with a
therapist whose expertise
fits your unique needs.
And what's so great about BetterHelp
where everything is done remotely,
is that you can work with a therapist
whose skills might not otherwise
be available in your area.
Within 48 hours you can start
messaging your therapist
at any time.
When you do reach out,
you'll receive timely and
thoughtful responses in return.
Additionally, you can schedule
your choice of secure,
phone, or video sessions to
receive counseling in real time.
In my case, I had my first
session with Sarah scheduled
three days after matching with her,
and honestly, it was one of
the best therapy experiences
that I've ever had.
She was so nice, so empathetic,
and so knowledgeable,
and I left with tools that
I can use to help myself
when I'm feeling super anxious.
And if you and your therapist
aren't a perfect match,
it's easy and free to switch to a new one.
So join the more than 2 million people
who have taken charge
of their mental health
with BetterHelp by visiting
betterhelp.com/wisecrack,
or just click the link
in the video description.
When you do, you'll get
10% off your first month.
That's betterH-E-L-P.com/wisecrack.
And now back to the show.
Now the Duffer brothers have been open
about how much they're
borrowing from the films
of yesteryear, specifically,
Stephen Spielberg's.
And they're not subtle.
"Stranger Things" has been
filled with references
to 1980s movies from the
jump, and has always shown
just how saturated the kids are
in the decade's pop culture.
- What if the bad people kidnapped her?
What if they're forcing her to say this?
- [Nancy] I need you to answer.
- It's like Lando Calrissian.
Don't answer.
- [Helen] "Stranger Things"
is hardly the first TV show
to peddle in nostalgia
but its salience today may
be indicative of our times.
Scholar Svetlana Boym calls nostalgia
"an incurable modern condition,"
describing its ubiquity
as "a defense mechanism
"in a time of accelerated rhythms of life
"and historical upheavals."
That is to say, when our world is changing
and the present feels
precarious, like, um,
right this (beep) second,
we collectively experience
what Boym describes
as, "a yearning for a different time.
"The time of our childhood,
"the slower rhythms of our dreams."
She noted way back in
2001 that American culture
was becoming increasingly self-referential
as it sought solace in a simpler past.
While the prevalence of
nostalgic content makes sense,
many remain skeptical about
how "Stranger Things" uses it.
Early on the New York Times
labeled "Stranger Things"
as "'80s karaoke," and
while that's pretty harsh,
especially if "Don't Stop
Believing" is your show stopper,
the show is definitely preoccupied
with that decade's
surface level aesthetic.
There's the fashion, the
toys, the technology,
the public spaces.
By saturating itself
with all of the dressings
of the '80s, the show fully
makes use of its period setting,
albeit in a way that often isn't relevant
to the actual plot.
Its focus on children and
adolescents also makes it ripe
for some of the strongest
pop culture associations
of the 1980s.
As marketing scholars William J. Havlena
and Susan L. Holak note,
we tend to have the strongest
nostalgic associations
with media and pop culture
from our adolescence,
which is presumably true for the Gen X'ers
and older millennials
who form a sizable chunk
of Netflix's audience.
And each moment in the
'80s of "Stranger Things"
is filled with all of the cool stuff
we associate with the decade,
creating an idealized version
that all of us can pine for.
And you could argue this idealism
has grown stronger each season.
Season two gave us a "Gremlin's"
riff with Dustin and Dart
and
the
whole
small-town-kids-fight-shady-invading-Russians
thing in season three is
straight up "Red Dawn."
This left season four feeling
disjointed in its potpourri
of genre tropes, lurching
from zany Spielbergian comedy
to a "Silence of the Lambs" ripoff.
By overtly mirroring movies
in its cinematography
and narrative, the show is engaging
in some good old fashioned intertextuality
or in other words, it's
creating a relationship
by mapping itself onto
an already existing work
with the same tone.
When Robin and Nancy's visit
with an accused serial killer
reminds us so vividly of
"Silence of the Lambs,"
we're reminded how we felt when
we first saw Anthony Hopkins
creep it up, and it puts
us in that head space.
No Chianti required.
(Hannibal hissing)
And intertextuality engages
with nostalgic media
in a specific way.
Scholar Frederic Jameson observes
that in an age of remakes
and nostalgic oversaturation,
intertextuality displaces real history
by substituting fact for
aesthetic style, or pseudohistory.
He writes that, "the nostalgic
film was never a matter
"of some old-fashioned
representation of historical content,
"but instead approach the past
"through stylistic connotation,
"conveying pastness by the
glossy qualities of the image."
Referencing the media of the past
rather than the actual
history is the priority.
But not everyone watching
"Stranger Things" today
was even alive in the '80s.
So what are they experiencing
when they indulge
in this virtual
reconstruction of the decade?
A little something scholar
Arjun Appadurai calls
armchair nostalgia, or ersatz nostalgia.
That is, "nostalgia
without lived experience
"or collective historical memory."
In his criticism of
nostalgia-tinged advertising
and merchandising which "Stranger Things"
has done its fair share of,
Appadurai argues that such media
creates nostalgia "for
things that never were.
"This imagined nostalgia thus
inverts the temporal logic
"of fantasy and creates much deeper wants
"than simple envy,
imitation, or greed could,
"by themselves, invite."
Interestingly enough, a lot
of young people's nostalgia
for the world depicted
in "Stranger Things"
is actually based on
nostalgia for the 1980s movies
that they watched in their youth
which defined that decade in their minds.
Thus a pseudohistory is born.
And that's the thing about pseudohistory.
It erases some of the uglier truths
of the time period depicted.
Sure, early seasons of "Stranger Things"
are hardly all fun in games.
There's a genuine darkness
that underscores it
from the get-go,
most obviously the
disappearance of a cute kid.
But that darkness is defined
by an unambiguous evil,
rendering the conflict that
ensues almost childlike
in its simplicity.
There's no empathizing with the Demogorgon
no matter what your fondness
for Venus fly traps may be.
Mind flayer is more of the same.
In this way, the darkness
of the Upside Down
in the first two seasons of the show
threatens the essential
lightness of the world above.
And that threat only escalates
as future seasons attempt
to complicate the balance.
Now there's a strong case
to be made that season three
of "Stranger Things"
marked a turning point
for the show's relationship with nostalgia
as it became less about reveling
in the commercial delights
of 1980s youth culture and
ventured closer to critique.
Obviously, there's still
plenty of production design
to make you pine for the '80s.
Half the freaking season
is set at a shopping mall, after all.
But we learned that the mall
isn't all fun and games.
It's a sign of Reagan-era corporatization
that's displacing tons of
longstanding mom and pop shops.
When intern Nancy points this
out to the local newspaper,
though, it's brushed off
as a matter of course,
unremarkable in pro-business,
Reagan-era America.
(men laughing)
What's more, unlike the
earlier ambient nostalgia,
this season's narrative revolves around
real anxieties from the '80s.
Most notably you have the Cold War
and the USSR's army plays a key role
as the show's first real human antagonist.
They want to use the Upside Down
to aid their Cold War agenda.
They set up camp in a giant lab
beneath Hawkins' Starcourt Mall
with the help of a
colluding, power-hungry mayor
who puts on a patriotic fair
while facilitating a communist invasion.
The Cold War paranoia about
a covert Russian infiltration
aided and abetted by
politicians is thus realized,
as well as Cold War-era anxieties
that the Soviets would use mind control
to turn Americans into commie zombies.
And though there's
plenty of fun to be had,
it's arguably using nostalgia
for mildly darker purposes
than it has before
By making these elements
central to the narrative.
"Stranger Things" is
seemingly acknowledging
that the '80s might not really have been
as simple and chill as its
portrayal led us to believe.
Surprise!
It marks a deliberate effort to engage
with the reality of the decade,
which was not just one big
game of Dungeons and Dragons.
But while season three tried
to address darker aspects
of the time, it didn't really pull it off.
In theory, the way "Stranger
Things" integrates issues
like corporatization
and Cold War anxieties
removed some of the shows
rose-tinted naivete.
But it also introduces
an element of whiplash
that undermines its own premise.
Nancy's newsroom critique
of corporatization
is quickly overshadowed
by all the fun antics
enjoyed at the mall.
And when it comes to
the Cold War narrative,
the show ultimately settles
for simplicity over complexity,
resolving nuanced, real world
issues by blaming everything
on the spooky, unambiguously evil Russians
and their monster friends.
This invasion obviously, as we noted,
draws pretty explicitly
from the film "Red Dawn,"
invoking the same happy
nostalgia that it does
for those of us who watched
Spielberg films in the '90s.
By letting us revel in
the intertextuality,
we can immediately conclude
that the kids are gonna triumph over evil.
Intertextuality strikes again.
Maybe the show was trying
to critique that brand
of feverish Cold War-era American media.
But if so, it doesn't really
signpost that intention.
Mostly, it depicts the Cold War
with a false sense of simplicity,
just as warm and fuzzy nostalgia
suggests a desirable
simplicity of its own.
(explosion banging)
(mind flayer screaming)
So, in trying to critique
its '80s setting,
season three still seems to conclude
that the time was simpler
than the present day.
But if season three tried and failed
to critique '80s nostalgia,
then season four arguably embraces nuance
in order to further its commentary
on nostalgia at large.
The most obvious way it does so
is by invoking the Satanic Panic,
a real-world '80s moral
panic which sparked fears
that things like Dungeons and
Dragons, or heavy metal music
were leading kids to
worship Satan, or like,
do ritual murders.
Not coincidentally, both of those things
were enjoyed by social
outcasts and nonconformists.
This added to the stigma
and other-ising of folks
who were already rendered pariahs
by the conservative social
norms of the decade.
This was, after all, an era
that looked back quite fondly
on the rampant conformity of the '50s.
And this clearly applies
to our protagonists
who are prime examples
of this sort of othering.
Previously, we had seen our
plucky adolescent friends
being bullied or excluded, but
this is the first real sense
we get that nonconformity
in Reagan-era America
wasn't just socially unadvisable,
it was potentially
criminal, as plenty of folks
convicted of dubious charges
during the Satanic Panic
could tell you.
And whether it's for their
interests, or their identity,
or their mental health issues,
"Stranger Things" asks to care about folks
who are in danger of
'80s-style societal scorn.
In a subversive twist,
it is only the outsiders
who are able to believe the truth:
that a Dungeons and Dragons-style monster
is on the hunt in Hawkins.
Meanwhile, the jocks and cops
all lead to the conclusion
that the freak, Eddie Munson
is responsible for the murders.
And during other moments on the show,
some of the trappings of the '80s
that might have once been celebrated
become dark and troubling.
Like Eleven's horrible day
at the roller skating rink
where a colorful, fun, retro trope
turns completely haunting.
(children laughing)
(Eleven yelps)
But arguably the show's best exploration
of the perils of nostalgia
is in its preoccupation with trauma
and mental health struggles.
We know lots of people have
been talking about this,
but we think it's worth diving deeper
as we examine whether the show can
successfully subvert its own nostalgia.
Most relevantly, there's
Hopper's backstory,
which we finally learn.
Like so many men of the era,
his guilt and substance abuse
issues were rooted in trauma
from his service in Vietnam.
- Ever since I was 18,
and some letter of induction
in the mail Uncle Sam
wants me to go fight some war in a jungle.
- We learned specifically
that he was assigned
to the Agent Orange division.
Ostensibly an herbicide
to remove Vietnamese defenders'
tactical edge in the jungle,
Agent Orange was also super toxic,
causing widespread
disability and birth defects.
The U.S. troops assigned
to the Agent Orange corp
were kept in the dark
as to its true nature,
and many suffered its effects.
- The horror followed us, clung to us.
- [Helen] Hopper blames himself
for his daughter's cancer,
and for not warning his wife
about the risks caused by his exposure.
- We had a baby and she was,
um, she was born healthy.
She was perfect.
You know, Sarah, and then she died.
- His resulting descent
into substance abuse
mirrors the experience of
many Vietnam War veterans.
Many struggled with PTSD or
other mental health troubles,
or were denied social services,
or even ended up unhoused.
Here we see that not
everything about the '80s
is something to be nostalgic for.
Coupled with the very
real brutality of life
in a Soviet gulag, we also see the darker,
less cartoonish reality of the Cold War.
Then more abstractly,
there's El's season arc
which sees her literally
reliving her younger life
under the care of Papa.
And this serves as a good
reminder that not everyone
would be stoked to return
to their childhood.
And in some of the season's
most powerful scenes
we watch as she delves into
her most horrific memories
of a massacre at the lab.
The pain of reliving her
trauma feels equal and opposite
to the nostalgic joy
viewers might have felt
reliving their own '80s
childhoods, real or imagined,
in the earlier seasons.
The trauma that El has
spent so long blocking
from her memory feels
completely oppositional
to the whole idea of nostalgia
that the show was rooted in.
And it's probably the best example
of the show's evolving maturity.
Of course, trauma has always
undergirded "Stranger Things,"
whether in Will's struggles
to get back to real life
after his time on the Upside Down,
or El's ongoing flashbacks
about being separated from her mother.
But by focusing on it
throughout the season,
the show is taking what was subtext
and making it central to the plot.
It's symptomatic of "Stranger
Things'" slow descent
into a darker worldview.
It's been slowly peeling
back its own nostalgia
like an onion to reveal the
real trauma that lingers
under even the happiest
memories of '80s childhood.
And because we've come
to love the characters
as tropes from '80s films,
it takes us by surprise
when the show actually stops
to examine their pain.
And that examination, and the
growth that comes with it,
subverts our ultimately
nostalgic view of them.
It serves as a strong reminder
that looking backwards
as a person, or as a nation,
can be as painful as it is joyous.
"Stranger Things" seems to be earnest
in its attempts at critiquing nostalgia.
But ultimately, these efforts lead
to a sort of internal conflict of interest
because alongside, say,
Hopper's discussion
of his time in Vietnam,
we still have the same nostalgic callbacks
the series was originally beloved for.
That's understandable.
Their audience has come to
expect as much from the show.
But it still creates a kind
of cognitive dissonance.
In fact, in this season, the
show even goes kind of meta
with its nostalgia,
featuring new flashbacks
to past beloved moments
from earlier in the series.
This creates a sort of
double nostalgia for us;
a nostalgia of remembering our
first time watching the show.
You could argue that this
is a way for the creators
to demonstrate just how
much things have changed,
but arguably, it skirts
the edge of fan service.
The darker that "Stranger Things" goes,
the more these twin threads
of celebratory nostalgia
and critique of nostalgia
start to chafe together.
So in sum, we'd argue
that "Stranger Things"
can't really subvert
the very same nostalgia
it actively invokes.
You can't have your nostalgia
cake and critique it, too.
And let's face it, the show's
thrills and spills escapism
is why we all got hooked to begin with.
If season one had ground to a halt
to explore Joyce Byers'
experience of single,
working-class motherhood,
would we have kept watching?
There's not much room in the whimsical,
Spielbergian paradigm for
examining the full-on complexity
of real-world politics,
or the nuanced and
highly-subjective effects
that they have on us as human beings.
But it can do compelling character work.
And we'd argue that season four
was the best example of that.
So "Stranger Things" mostly remains a show
that creates intertextual nostalgia
to make its audience remember,
or pretend they remember, the '80s.
And if it happens to do
so to commercial ends,
then all the better
to merchandise the (beep)
out of Eleven, right?
As historian Gary Cross puts it,
"All nostalgias consist of
organizers and participants.
"But today the organizers
increasingly are marketers,
"and participants are consumers."
That is to say, being nostalgic for an era
naturally makes you more
likely to buy (beep)
that reminds you of that era.
Hey, let he who lives in a glass house
cast the first Walkman.
But this type of nostalgia
has a potentially more
insidious side, too.
The imagined past, like
those invoked in the show,
are also used to fuel
a political nostalgia
that has real world consequences,
like a right-wing yearning for a past
where America was a place
full of faith, family,
and straight people who owned guns,
or the liberal nostalgia
for a world of tolerance
and ethical capitalism.
In both cases, this nostalgia
functionally distracts us
from critically evaluating the present.
It convinces us that the only
way forwards is backwards.
It might not be a big deal
when this inspires us to,
say, buy a two liter of
Coke with our Pizza Hut,
but it can potentially be harmful
when it starts to shape
our political reality.
Luckily, "Stranger Things"
seems content to stay out
of the pesky boring politics
that constitute adult life,
at least for now.
But what do you think?
Does "Stranger Things" succeed
at critiquing the nostalgia
that it's based in,
or was season four a
failed lab experiment?
Let us know in the comments.
Thanks to our patrons
for all their support.
And don't miss out on
our new Patreon perks.
And remember you can
join us every Thursday
for our weekly live stream.
Throw fireworks at that subscribe button
like you're vanquishing an
inter-dimensional monster
and don't forget to ring that bell.
As always, thanks for watching,
and good luck making that deal with God.
Later.
(mid-tempo music)